avril 51 il ya tout juste soixante dix
ans une revue mythique voyait le jour
les cahiers du cinéma truffaut godard
chabrol avant de devenir les cinéastes
de la nouvelle vague
ces réalisateurs se sont d'abord fait
connaître par leurs plumes avec une idée
à défendre le cinéma d'auteur c'est une
revue qui ne juge pas la petite semaine
et ça repose sur ce postulat que qu'un
film est quelque chose qui dure et que
ce n'est pas un simple produit de
consommation c'est une oeuvre qui
aujourd'hui un film est d'abord perçu
comme l'oeuvre de son réalisateur
jusque dans les années 50 on allait
surtout voir un film pour son scénario
ces acteurs ou son genre ce que déplore
jean-luc godard en 1964 en france on
croit au genre on pense que dans une
tragédie on doit pleurer et donné des
coups de couteau et que dans une comédie
on doit rire et donné des coups de pied
au derrière avec les cahiers du cinéma
c'est le style c'est l'esthétique du
cinéaste qui devient prépondérante
c'est un phénomène de rupture c'est
finalement l'empêcheur de tourner en
rond
les critiques des cahiers s'attaque à ce
qu'ils appellent le cinéma de papa leur
tête de turc
les scénaristes jean aurenche et pierre
bost en 1954 dans un article restée
célèbre
le duo est violemment pris à partie par
françois truffaut le cinéaste sont
explique des années plus tard les
adaptations de rang chez boss consistait
à prendre un roman comme le diable au
corps comme rouge et noir est à dire bon
on a une heure et demie on va en faire
28 scène et puis on faisait 28 sept
finalement ça revenait un peu à
transformer des romans en pièces de
théâtre
devant ces critiques jean orange réagi
comme ici en 1980 étaient frappés par la
violence avec laquelle il aurait attaqué
vraiment et par écrit un scénario c'est
aussi une oeuvre littéraire nom de dieu
les plumes des caillons en fait les yeux
tournés vers hollywood
le seul des scènes du cinéma d'auteur là
où tous les autres n'y voit que du
divertissement aux cahiers on va
défendre ce cinéma que tout le monde
n'est prise on dit que c'est un cinéma
naïf infantile et journalistes des
cahiers vont découvrir en amérique des
hauteurs de filles par exemple hitchcock
par exemple howard hawks aux états unis
cet éloge surprendra les réalisateurs
eux mêmes comme le rappelle gilles jacob
alors délégué général du festival de
cannes et ancien journaliste aux cahiers
lui considéré qu'ils étaient des
artisans on essayait de montrer que ces
gens là avaient un univers et il tombait
des nues quand on a dit à houston on lui
a montré mon article mais qu'est ce que
c'est que cette histoire
la tragédie de la rapacité la poésie de
l'échec dans l'univers estonien mais moi
j'ai pas d'univers c'est des inventions
de critiques européens ce que défendent
en fait les cahiers du cinéma
c'est l'idée qu'un réalisateur peut
afficher des ambitions commerciales et
être un artiste à part entière
[Musique]